i just came up with new neopronouns that
combine he him she her and they them
okay
so hear me out be them theirs okay they
them their whatever you want to consider
it right let's take the first one d okay
this combines
she he and they right
they
[Music]
that's what they said you know i don't
know what you're talking about what are
you talking about i don't know what
we're yelling about i mean just a
refresher the word v actually does have
a meaning right like v with two e's at
the end means you in english so now
you're just taking that term and you've
turned it not into they but also into
they and he
and also she
and they and him
but not her that's another word that's
thor's all of this is designed to
confuse all of this is designed to
convey less information because as it
turns out there is no person who is male
female and also plural those people
don't exist plural